okay so this quick video is going to
explain the similarities and the
differences between positive and
negative feedback so let's get started
alright so before I even get into what
is the difference between the two I do
want to address a myth that positive
feedback is good for you and negative
feedback is bad for you it's very much a
myth the reality is that both are
crucial to our survival remember that
both of these are natural processes that
are maintained by the body well let's go
ahead and actually start with negative
feedback negative feedback is what
regulates most of the homeostatic levels
of the body and it's the process where
our body will reverse a change that may
be occurring and this is what keeps our
bodies at set points for instance our
temperature has a set point of about
ninety eight point six degrees if we get
too hot we will sweat if we get too cold
will shiver all designed to keep us at
our setpoint I want to start with an
analogy of negative feedback in your
home somewhere in your home centrally
located you have a thermostat on one of
your walls and maybe tucked away in the
utility room is the furnace well
connected to the furnace or all the
heating and air-conditioning vents and
ducts and there's a wire that connects
your thermostat to the furnace well we
often set our thermostat for a desirable
temperature that we want to be
comfortable at maybe 77 degrees
Fahrenheit but maybe it's really cold
maybe it's only 74 degrees inside your
house because you left the windows open
your thermostat will send a signal to
the furnace the furnace will respond
will respond by pumping out a bunch of
heat around the house and over the next
few minutes your home will warm back up
until it gets back to the desired
setpoint at that time everything turns
off great example of negative feedback
because your home responded to the cold
temperature and perform an action to
warm the home up
so let's stay on the topic of body
temperature and explain how our body
temperature is a great example of
negative feedback so we have a set
temperature of about 37 degrees Celsius
or 98.6 degrees Fahrenheit but let's say
like the woman in the picture you go for
a walk you know the longer you walk the
more heat your body generates and so now
the borman's temperature is up to thirty
seven point eight degrees
thirty-eight point one degrees we've all
experienced what happens next we start
to produce a lot of sweat sweat is
designed to cool us off but how how does
sweat actually cool us down so as the
sweat begins to evaporate heat is
carried away from the body so the more
sweat that we produce the more sweat
will evaporate the more heat will be
carried away from the body
and over the course of time we get back
to the 37 degrees Celsius the setpoint
great example of negative feedback
because the body's temperature was
returned to the normal set point well
the opposite is true what if we're
outside on a really cold day the longer
were outside on a cold day our body
temperature drops thirty six point six
thirty six point two and so the longer
we're outside the colder we get well
what happens in this case well this is
something that we've all experienced
when we're really cold we start to shake
and shiver the shaking in the shivering
generates Heat you know muscles are
rubbing pretty either you know producing
friction which generates heat and the
longer we shiver and shake of course
eventually produce more and more and
more heat until eventually we get really
close to the setpoint and when we
finally reach that setpoint 37 degrees
Celsius a signal will be sent to the
brain and in the the shivering will stop
we've returned to the normal set point
that's a great example again of negative
feedback negative feedback returns the
body to the setpoint in this case 37
degrees Celsius
so how about another example of negative
feedback you know how the body maintains
a level of blood sugar blood glucose is
a great example of negative feedback
there's a small amount of glucose in our
blood that's what the G represents in my
picture up here and so this represents
the normal amount of blood sugar but
anytime we have a meal after our meal is
digested the glucose enters into the
bloodstream at this point we have an
elevated blood sugar level and so an
alert will be sent to the brain the
brain will send a signal to the pancreas
so the brain will here's our pancreas
the brain will send a signal to the
pancreas and the pancreas is going to
respond by releasing the letter I in my
animation the letter i' stands for the
hormone called insulin insulin is going
to help lower the blood sugar back to
that normal 0.1% level so here we are
back in the area where we started we see
again the elevated blood sugar again our
person just had a meal and the pancreas
just released a bunch of AI for insulin
the insulin will attach itself to these
little doorways these little channels
that are found on cells and the insulin
causes these channels to open and once
the channels are open I hope you can
predict what's going to happen next so
the glucose is going to diffuse through
those open channels well I hope you see
what that did to the level of sugar in
the blood that reduced the blood glucose
level back to its normal 0.1% so this is
how this is again a great example of
negative feedback here it's simply
because negative feedback reverses the
change the change is that the blood
sugar became elevated and so the body
responded in a way to lower the blood
sugar back to its 0.1% setpoint
great example of negative feedback
well what about the opposite again here
is our 0.1% normal blood sugar but let's
say you know a person's really been
exercising for a real long time and
they're running out of fuel you know
glucose is like a fuel so let's say
you're over exercising and now we're
getting really low on blood our on
glucose so our blood sugar it's not
normal anymore we now have a reduced
blood sugar again there's a way to
combat this so in the case of having
reduced blood sugar the brain will
receive a signal that the blood sugar is
too low instead of the brain responding
and sending a signal to the pancreas in
this case because the blood sugar is too
low the brain will respond by sending a
signal to our liver here's a picture of
our liver and our liver has a bunch of
stored glucose in it and so the liver
will respond by releasing extra storages
of glucose into the blood that brings
the level back up to the 0.1% and this
will continue the the liver will
continue to release the the stored
amounts of glucose until the blood sugar
is back to that 0.1 percent again great
example of negative feedback because the
body has responded and returned the body
to a normal set point so I hope after
going over those examples we can dispel
that myth that negative feedback is bad
for you again the reality is both are
crucial both negative and positive
feedback are crucial well let's actually
shift our attention now to positive
feedback you know this is a feedback
where a rapid change is needed and this
is a process where your body will
actually encourage whatever the change
is it will encourage the change and
allow it to proceed even faster and so
the body will actually move away from a
set point so let's go over some examples
of this so I hope a good analogy of
positive feedback in our home comes to
the use of smoke detectors you have a
smoke detector in every room of your
house and let's say a fire begins in the
living room well the smoke detector
there is
- the fire will probably be the one that
activates first and turns on the loud
piercing alert noise but positive
feedback is different than negative
positive feedback encourages the alert
to one by one all the other smoke
detectors will turn on and activate the
loud piercing noise to hopefully wake
everybody up to get everyone to safety
notice how the alert was amplified it
was encouraged it was increased so let's
look at a biological example of positive
feedback a great example are the
pregnancy contractions that a woman
experiences before giving birth so at
first pregnancy contractions or the
muscles of the uterus begin to stretch
and contract in a very slow manner and
when the contractions begin very slowly
an alert will be sent to the brain the
brain will respond by sending out a
hormone the hormone by that by the way
is called oxytocin and that's what the
black triangles represent well how does
how do the muscles of the uterus respond
to oxytocin the muscles of the uterus
respond by contracting even faster with
the hopes of delivering the child even
quicker so the the contractions are not
stopped and returned to zero that would
be negative feedback the contractions
are promoted and allowed to proceed so
again this is why it's a great example
of positive feedback so how about
another example of positive feedback
another great example is what happens
when we're injured and we form a little
blood clot so here's a case where a
person got scratched and you know
they're they're starting to bleed so
those damaged injured cells begin to
release little proteins into the blood
and what's the purpose why would they do
this what is the the goal if you think
about it the goal is to plug that injury
so those damaged cells released a bunch
of proteins that will actually attract
platelets and platelets are very
important in stopping the the stopping
the bleeding then the platelets respond
by releasing
more proteins which attract even more
platelets and then they respond by
releasing proteins which attract even
more platelets and then those platelets
respond by releasing proteins which
attract even more and eventually
eventually enough platelets kind of
close and fill in this injury where the
person stops bleeding but again a great
example of positive feedback because the
the the change was encouraged the
clotting was encouraged in allowed to
proceed at an even faster rate it wasn't
it wasn't turned off so here you go
we've reached the end I hope this was a
good understanding of the differences
between positive feedback and negative
feedback if you have any questions post
them in the comments below and perhaps I
can get a chance to answer them thank
you and good luck